on November 22nd 2014 a burst of x-rays
was detected by assassin that's the
all-sky automated survey for supernovae
but this was no supernova the signal
came from the center of a galaxy around
290 million light-years away and what we
now believe happened was a star came too
close to a supermassive black hole with
a mass millions of times that of our Sun
and it was eaten the black hole fed on
the star and yes this is the actual
terminology astrophysicists use to
describe it
events like these are thought to be rare
occurring maybe once every 10 200,000
years in a galaxy they're called tidal
disruption events or tidal disruption
flares as the star approached the side
closest to the black hole experienced a
much stronger gravitational pull than
the other side ripping the star to
shreds matter spiraling into the black
hole formed an accretion disk an annular
ring of gas and dust that's accelerating
and heating up emitting visible light UV
and x-rays observable from Earth now
what's remarkable about this event is
that it transformed a dormant or
quiescent black hole when it wasn't
really feeding into one that we can
observe thanks to the matter falling in
from That star and this is what it
looked like okay if you're disappointed
check out these artists renditions of
the same event
but if you're cynical you might say well
how do we know that's what really
happened what if the scientists are just
making this up to get more grant funding
or to inspire people to go into science
well I'll explain how we know this is
actually what went down but first things
got weirder scientists trained three
x-ray telescopes to observe this part of
the sky for years after the event and
what they found was a strong and regular
pulse of x-rays brightening and dimming
every 131 seconds and it shows up in the
data from all three telescopes they
observed periodically over 450 days but
the pulse maintained this rhythm and
didn't get weaker in fact as time went
on the relative strength of the pulse
got stronger modulating the x-ray signal
by around 40% and what was causing these
periodic flashes of x-rays and what
could it tell us about the black hole
well let's back up because black holes
are some of the simplest objects in the
universe by that I just mean that they
are characterized by only two attributes
mass and spin
okay there's also charge but since black
holes should essentially be neutral mass
and spin are the two that count mass is
relatively easy to determine far away
from a black hole you can even use
Newtonian physics by measuring the
gravitational effects of the black hole
on other bodies you can estimate the
mass of the black hole this has been
done and black holes have been found
with masses ranging from just a few
times our Sun stellar-mass black holes
up to billions of solar masses
supermassive black holes it's generally
accepted that there is a supermassive
black hole at the centres of most
galaxies including our own but what
about spin since black holes form from
collapsing stars and all known stars
rotate all black holes should also be
rotating I mean what are the chances
that a bunch of matter just collapses
into a point perfectly with no rotation
it's just not going to happen and then
additional matter falling into the black
hole contributes its angular momentum so
like a figure skater pulling their arms
into a point object you can imagine
black holes get spinning pretty fast but
spin is harder to measure because unlike
mass it only affects objects relatively
close to the black
Cole but there is a way to do it
actually three ways to understand all of
them you have to understand
ESCO in Newtonian physics around a
compact mass you can place an object in
a circular orbit at any radius and it
will be stable it doesn't matter how
close you get this is not the case
according to general relativity here
there is an inner most stable circular
orbit with a radius known as R Isco
closer than this
and no orbits are stable they all fall
into the black hole so when you're
looking at a black hole that is feeding
the innermost edge of the accretion disk
is at R s Co what's useful for our
purposes is that RS co depends on the
spin of the black hole the faster it's
spinning the smaller our Isco becomes
assuming it's spinning in the same
direction as the matter in the accretion
disk the rotation enables particles to
orbit closer to the black hole than
they'd be able to for a non spinning
black hole so you can kind of think of
it as though the spin is supporting the
particles against the relentless pull of
gravity
now spin is normally discussed in terms
of a dimensionless parameter that ranges
from zero no spin to one maximum spin
though I guess you could also have spins
down to negative one if the black hole
is spinning in the opposite direction
from the accretion disk
now as spin increases our Isco decreases
by a factor of six shrinking down to the
size of the event horizon and this sets
what many scientists think is the
maximum span a black hole can have
because if the minimum stable orbit were
the size of the event horizon then light
could escape from the black hole
allowing us to see into the singularity
this is called a naked singularity and
it makes a lot of scientists
uncomfortable as yet there isn't a
strong theoretical reason why a black
hole can't exceed this maximum spin it's
just that we haven't seen one and the
thought of an exposed singularity just
kind of feels wrong
most suspect the maximum real world spin
parameter is around point nine nine
eight so how can you use our Isco to
measure the spin of a black hole well
first let's think about how we measure
the size of anything far away from us in
deep space like the radius of a star
most stars are so far away that they're
simply point objects in our telescope
so how can you figure out their radii
well first look at the spectrum of their
light by seeing how redshifted
absorption lines are you can determine
how far away the star is the spectrum
also tells you the temperature of the
star because it should approximate a
blackbody curve and now the power
radiated per unit area of the star is
strongly dependent on its temperature so
if you know how bright the star appears
from Earth how far away it is and how
much power it's radiating per unit area
well then you can work out its area and
hence its radius you can actually do
something very similar for a black holes
accretion disk just instead of
estimating the radius of a glowing
sphere you're estimating the radius of
the dark circle or Isco in the middle of
the glowing accretion disk then you can
use artists Co to find the spin
parameter this has been done for a
number of black holes revealing spin
parameters from around Point 1 up to
close to the maximum but this method
only works if the radiation from the
black hole is dominated by blackbody
radiation from the accretion disk which
often it's not another approach involves
looking at x-rays emitted by iron around
a black hole some black holes show a
distinct iron emission line but instead
of the single frequency you'd expect the
line is broadened by factors like the
Doppler shift due to the high velocity
of the iron in the accretion disk and
gravitational redshift due to the
extreme gravitational fields close to
the black hole by looking at the low
energy limit of the iron emission line
you can determine how close to the black
hole it was emitted and hence our Isco
but what if there is no bright iron
emission line well luckily there is a
third way and that is to look for
periodic oscillations in the data like
the repeated x-rays observed every 131
seconds the thinking is these cycles
must be caused by clumps of matter
orbiting the black hole and if frequency
is that high
they must be orbiting very close in
probably near our Isco even that close
they'd be going half the speed of light
but what kind of clumps or objects would
these be well the study's authors argue
the best candidate involves an unlikely
scenario years before the tidal
disruption event they proposed there was
a white dwarf star in orbit around this
black hole now it might be stable
orbiting in this way for perhaps one or
200 years by itself it wouldn't be
visible from Earth but then the other
star wandered by and was ripped apart in
the tidal disruption event its mass fell
in toward the black hole forming an
accretion disk with the addition of this
stellar debris the white dwarf was
cloaked in glowing matter creating an
x-ray hotspot orbiting the black hole
and its period would directly relate to
the spin of the black hole in this case
the measured spin parameter turned out
to be at least 0.7 and possibly as high
as the theoretical maximum of 0.998
meaning objects in the accretion disk
were going at least half the speed of
light this is the first measurement of
spin made possible by a tidal disruption
event and the implication is that this
could provide a method for determining
the spin of black holes particularly
ones that have been dormant which is
about 95 percent of supermassive black
holes if they shred a star we get
insight into their spin now why is this
important well because it helps us
understand the origins of black holes
if supermassive black holes grow in size
mainly by feeding on a steady stream of
matter from within their own galaxy
you'd expect their spins to be very
large because the angular momentum of
that matter would be more or less
aligned so it would add up over time but
if instead supermassive black holes grow
predominantly by merging with other
large black holes you might expect their
spins to be lower because the spins of
two black holes are likely to be
randomly oriented rather than aligned as
we are able to measure the spins of more
black holes in different ways farther
out and therefore further back in time
we should be able to better understand
their growth and since supermassive
black holes lie at the centres of most
galaxies they also lie at the center of
an understanding of how those galaxies
have formed and evolved over billions of
years
[Music]